this is the height of idiocy but it
appears that Republicans are using
former NFL quarterback Colin
Kaepernick's image for a fundraising
email and that they've digitally
darkened his skin to make him look
blacker in the ad this is the NRCC
which is the National Republican
Congressional Committee they sent out an
email on Wednesday and it was all about
the American flag who do you stand with
the ad asks Donald Trump and the Betsy
Ross flag or anti American flag Colin
Kaepernick before we even look at what
they did to Kaepernick skin I just want
to remind you that this entire flag
controversy is so stupid I mean it's
really depressing that this flag issue
would even be an issue
to fundraise around and that the right
even cares about this that's a really
sad commentary on our country most of
you probably already know and understand
that but then we get to the skin color
issue when you look side-by-side at the
original picture and the version of it
that was used in this Republican ad you
can see that Colin Kaepernick skin
clearly seems much darker in the picture
that's included in the ad in particular
when you look at his forearm
now the NRCC was asked about this they
are claiming it was not darkened what I
hate about this is that this is actually
not a new tactic but that it appears to
actually work okay this has been studied
in the 2008 campaign the McCain campaign
was also caught darkening Barack Obama's
skin when they published attack ads and
there was a study done in 2015 which
found that darkening the skin of
political opponents as stupid as it
sounds to many of us actually impacts
the impressions of voters about the
candidates and this isn't just
Republicans who do it the Hillary
Clinton campaign in 2008 was also
accused of darker darkening Barack
Obama's skin in ads so the underlying
idea is that no matter who you are
that's running no matter who you're
running against whether it's a
Democratic woman a Republican man the
idea is there's an unconscious bias that
is strongest against the darkest people
people with the darkest skin tone and
this is called colorism i mean this is
not a new concept
so it seems that it's an effective thing
to do shockingly enough so there's a few
different things that should make us I
guess I would say sad here
it's sad that political candidates would
do this they do it and they do it
because it's work because it works and
that's actually the saddest part for me
and then the absolutely dumbest part of
this goes way beyond darkening colin
kaepernick skin it's the sad reality
that people still care about this stupid
flag thing kneeling during the national
anthem is not disrespect to our troops
they fought and fight so that we retain
freedom of speech and expression it's
not that they fight to limit our
protests only to approved ones that
Republicans like that is not actually
freedom of speech and expression
kneeling during the national anthem is
not disrespect to the country it's
respect for the country in wanting to
change it for the better
that's what Colin Kaepernick was
kneeling for now you could disagree with
Kaepernick about the degree to which his
priorities should be priorities in the
country you could say I simply don't
think that Colin Kaepernick's concerns
actually rise to the level that Colin
Kaepernick believes they should or do
okay well I disagree with you but that's
an actual respectful and logical debate
to have but the idea that the mere
protests that Colin Kaepernick
participated in is somehow anti-american
or disrespectful to the flag or
disrespectful to our troops it's
disgusting that that actually qualifies
as a valid talking point to much of the
American right wing the catalyst for all
this right kneeling during the anthem
shouldn't even rank as a controversy and
the fact that it has is the biggest
indictment of all on a huge portion of
our American political constituents and
that's why we can't convince them not to
vote for Trump in November of 2020 I've
said it before I will continue to say it
we have to win despite them not with
them and we need to get non voters to
vote because people who believe that
it's a real tragedy that Colin
Kaepernick knelt during the or kneeled
during the National
we're not going to be able to bring them
to our site if you love learning new
things you probably want to check this
out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video